this is Charles a San Esteban island  chuckwalla part of the iguana family  Chuck Wallace are the largest of the  five species they are endangered due to  hunting and feral animals preying on  their eggs  Charles is native to San Esteban island  a small island in the Gulf of California  Mexico it is only in this region where  the San Esteban Chuck Wallace can be  found their coloration provides critical  camouflage from predators they don't  drink water instead getting all the  water they need from the plants they eat  San Esteban Chuck Wallace can reach over  two and a half feet in size they are  very well adapted for desert life and  enjoy basking in the Sun in temperatures  consistently in the low hundreds this is  the San Esteban char koala  [Music]